>> Sean: A LITTLE POISON THERE.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
BERNIE SANDERS ARE SET TO FACE
OFF IN THE SENATE PROJECT.
STREAMING LIVE AND EXCLUSIVELY
THIS MONDAY AT NOON EASTERN ON
FOX NATION, BRET BAIER WILL BE
MODERATING THE DEBATE AND JOINS
US TO TELL US MORE.
BRET, GET TO SEE YOU.
I'VE DONE A LOT OF THESE
DEBATES.
WHAT ARE THE RULES OF THE DEBATE
AND ARE THESE POLITICIANS BE
ABLE TO DIG IN TO THE ISSUES SO
WHERE WE CAN SEE BOTH SIDES AND
HAVE THEM SPAR?
>> I LOVE THE INTROING THESE
SENATE DEBATES WITH POISON.
THAT'S REALLY A GOOD THING TO
DO.
BUT LINDSEY GRAHAM AND BERNIE
SANDERS ARE POISED FOR THIS.
YOU CAN'T THINK OF TWO FIGURES
THAT ARE MORE FAR APART AND
THEIR ABILITY TO ARTICULATE IT,
I'VE DEALT WITH BOTH OF THEM
BEFORE.
THIS FORMAT IS OXFORD STYLE.
IT IS OPENING STATEMENTS AND
REBUTTALS AND THEN THERE'S A Q&A
SESSION WITH ME AS THE
MODERATOR.
BASICALLY I'M KEEPING THEM IN
THE GUARDRAILS.
THE WHOLE PROCESS HERE IS TO TRY
TO GET THE OLD WAY THAT THE
SENATE OPERATED WITH DISCUSSION
AND SUBSTANCE, BACKING UP WHAT
YOU SAY, NOT JUST TWEETS AGAINST
THE WALL OR SOUND BITES THAT GET
PICKED UP.
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
REFRESHING.
IT'S AN HOUR.
IT'S A COLLABORATION WITH THE
BIPARTISAN POLICY CENTER.
THE EDWARD M. KENNEDY INSTITUTE
AND THE ORRIN HATCH FOUNDATION.
IT'S BASED ON THE PREMISE THAT
SENATOR TED KENNEDY AND ORRIN
HATCH WERE DIFFERENT IN THE WAY
THEY LOOKED AT THE WORLD AND
POLITICS BUT THEY GOT TOGETHER
AND ARGUED ABOUT THINGS THAT
THEY DISAGREED ABOUT.
>> Sean: DAGEN?
>> Dagen: ALLOW ME ONE TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE POISON.
THE CHEVY VEGA OF AMERICAN ROCK
BANDS.
AND LINDSEY GRAHAM AND BERNIE
SANDERS HATE EACH OTHER DEEP
DOWN.
WILL THAT BUBBLE UP?
>> THERE WILL BE SPARRING.
WHEN YOU GET INTO THE ISSUES,
THEY'RE SO FAR APART ON SOME
THINGS, THEY WILL BE SOME, YOU
KNOW, POINTED JABS, I'M SURE.
BUT IT'S MUCH MORE OF A
DISCUSSION ABOUT A CONVERSATION.
I'M STEERING IT.
AS I PREPARE FOR THIS, IT IS
MORE ABOUT GETTING THEM TO
ENGAGE AND LESS ABOUT ME PROBING
THEM AND FOLLOWING UP.
THAT SORT OF THING.
>> Will: I KNOW YOU HAVE SEVERAL
BUCKS.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT ON "FOX AND
FRIENDS" WEEKEND.
I'M CURIOUS HOW HARD IT IS TO
BOOK THESE DEBATES.
THERE'S A LITTLE SENTIMENT, NOT
EXCLUSIVELY, BUT PRIMARILY ON
THE LEFT TO NOT GIVE HONOR TO
YOUR OPPONENT'S IDEAS BUT
CONFRONTING THEM OR DEBATING
THEM.
HAS IT BEEN DIFFICULT TO BOOK?
>> NO.
SENATOR SANDERS HAS ALWAYS BEEN
GOOD AND ENGAGING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SENATOR
SANDERS SUPPORTS SAYS HE
BELIEVES WHO HE IS AND STANDS BY
IT.
PEOPLE THAT DEAL WITH SENATOR
SANDERS SAY THAT.
SENATOR GRAHAM I TALKED TO HIM
ABOUT IT THE OTHER NIGHT.
SO THEY'RE UNIQUE FIGURES.
SENATOR SANDERS IS ONE OF THEM.
AS WE GO FORWARD, WE'LL SEE HOW
THIS DEVELOPS.
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE
INTERESTING CHARACTERS ALONG THE
WAY.
A SET OF SERIES OF THREE
PLANNED.
WE HAVE NOT UNVEILED OTHER
THINGS.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE PART IN THIS
ONE AND DO MORE IN THE FUTURE.
IT'S STREAMING ON FOX NATION
LIVE.
WE'LL PUT A PIECE OF IT ON
"SPORT REPORT" AND MORE ON FOX
NEWS CHANNEL AFTERWARDS.
>> Jeanine: BRET, I'M CURIOUS
WHAT YOU THINK TEND GAME IS WITH
RESPECT TO THIS JANUARY 6
COMMISSION.
>> JUDGE, THAT WAS MY BIG QUEST
IN THE POSTGAME ANALYSIS ON
SHANNON'S SHOW.
WHERE THE BLUEPRINT THAT THEY
HAVE.
ARE THEY LOOKING FOR A CRIMINAL
CHARGE OR LOOKING TO TRY TO
PREVENT FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
FROM RUNNING FROM OFFICE AGAIN.
I AGREE WITH JESSICA.
THERE WERE NEW NUGGETS, SEVERAL
OF THEM THROUGHOUT THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BACK UP
WITH TESTIMONY.
BENNIE THOMPSON SAID AFTERWARDS
IN AN INTERVIEW THAT THERE WILL
BE WITNESS TESTIMONY THAT TIES
THE PROUD BUYS AND OATH KEEPERS
TO TRUMP'S INNER CIRCLE.
IF THAT HAPPENS, THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT NEWS IN THAT REGARD.
I THINK SOME OF THE THINGS SAID
ABOUT INNER WORKINGS WHILE IT
WAS GOING ON ARE NEW.
BUT THE BIGGEST QUESTION IS, HOW
CAN THEY KEEP EVERYTHING
TOGETHER IN SEVEN COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND WHERE ARE THEY
GOING AT THE END.
>> Jessica: BRET, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME LAST NIGHTS AND
BACKING ME UP A LITTLE THERE.
IT'S LONELY AT THIS STABLE.
I WANTED TO ADD ON TO JANINE'S
QUESTION AND ASK YOU ABOUT THE
END GAME, BUT AS FAR AS THE
MID-TERMS.
IF YOU THINK THIS WILL HAVE ANY
MEDIATE POLITICAL EFFECT ON WHAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO THE POLLS
FOR IN NOVEMBER?
>> I THINK YOU KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THIS.
I THINK THAT MOST PEOPLE
DECIDE -- FIRST OF ALL, WE'RE IN
JUNE.
RIGHT?
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TILL
NOVEMBER.
WHAT IS THE THING THAT IS
DRIVING MOST PEOPLE'S ANGST?
IT'S HOW YOUR PUTTING FOOD ON
THE TABLE, HOW YOU'RE PAYING
BILLS.
THE FACT THAT YOUR CHECK MAY
HAVE GONE UP, BUT YOU HAVE LESS
BECAUSE YOU'RE SPENDING THE
AVERAGE, ACCORDING TO MOODY'S
ANALYTICS, THAT A FAMILY IS
PAYING $460 MORE PER MONTH THAN
THEY WERE NOR THE SAME AMOUNT OF
GOODS AND SERVICES.
$460 MORE PER MONTH PER FAMILY.
THAT TRUMPS ANYTHING ELSE.
SO IS IT SIGNIFICANT IN THE BIG
PICTURE?
IT WAS A DARK DISMAL DAY FOR THE
COUNTRY AND ON CAPITOL HILL.
THEY NEED TO REMEMBER IT AND
THEY WILL.
BUT I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH IT
AFFECTS THE MID-TERMS.
>> Sean: YOU AGREE WITH JESSICA?
WE WON'T TAKE OFFEN